happy hump day reject nation it's greg
alba hey and i'm john the hump we are
the real rejects welcome to our youtube
channel if you're new you're probably
not but if you are hey this is my
cartoon now your personality oh boy a
Teen Titans go the to the movies
so yesterday I decided to do some
research and I watched about 45 minutes
worth the Teen Titans go and I realized
I am the target market you are the 4.8%
that was pretty annoyed watching it but
hey maybe in a movie format it might be
alright but guys really quick before we
watch this I wanted to give a thank you
to everyone who's been following us in
the Stardust app or almost at 4,000
followers over there so thank you guys
this awesome app that lets you do
30-second reactions or reviews for any
film TV show or trailer I just checked
today we have over a hundred ten post on
the Stardust app already a lot of
different things we've talked about
talking lots of flint we've got some of
the most posts out of anyone on the
Stardust app you haven't checked this
out there yet download the link in the
description box and follow us first
porfavor na ho let's check this out do
you know what makes a real hero it's not
the costume
[Music]
[Music]
do your thing
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
all right
[Music]
we're to watch The WB like rib their own
movies at a weird time like this with
the DC Universe constantly switching
through presidents always having new
plans and new directions that they want
to do constantly switching editors now
they're gonna be riffing on their own
material a little bit this show is it's
for kids the show is really for kids
where I felt like the Lego Batman movie
is something that kids and adults and
comic fans can really enjoy I think that
this film itself though is an entirely
different thing because it's very much
just for a little kid I watched some
episodes last night it's very kinetic
it's very hyper I mean they have a lot
of quick little references that you see
in like quick little snippets you might
even miss them throughout the show it's
cool now how they designed the world
like the head like Superman ice cream
shop but it comes up for like a split
second in the background Batman in
Commissioner Gordon or even in it and
they would they have like this weird
buddy relationship it feels like it
makes fun of the DC world for people who
are fans of the comics or know the world
but the jokes are all written for like
little little children and I only watch
like 45 minutes and honestly some of it
was a little hard to get through every
clip I've seen of this show has struck
me as being something that you have to
be in the target demo to like really
want to subject yourself yeah you gotta
like that kind of humor I guess I feel
like when I see references and and and
sometimes seeing what they're doing I'm
like oh this is kind of neat I kind of
like what they're doing here because it
is just about the teens what they do
when they're not saving lives what they
do when they're not being superheroes so
I like that approach something tells me
this will be the movie where they don't
do that where they have to fight really
have to fight crime yeah
yeah you want to probably get back to
the stuff that they would have been
doing and they not been fighting yeah I
can't it feels a little bit like it'll
probably be an annoying movie to me this
will hit perfectly for fans of the show
and it probably won't convert anybody
who's not a Finnish yeah I mean I'm
looking at right now as we're filming
this video the trailer has 15,000 views
a thousand likes 896 dislikes and it's
coming out at a weird time too because
the Teen Titans show is being filmed and
developed right now for the CW I think
it's with the CW and that's a
live-action show which has a darker more
serious look about and they're coming
out with this Cartoon Network spoof like
show of the Teen Titans I don't know if
this is good timing for this movie okay
I found out the audience for it that's
fine it just doesn't seem like the right
time for it unless they can take
advantage and sort of make fun of what's
been going on with the DC Universe as of
late that can make it more relatable
because one thing Lego Batman movie did
not do I think with them talking about
Wonder Woman and everyone loves Wonder
Woman and they care about her and so
they keep those kind of jokes there
might be something there more for the
adult audiences to be able to sit
through who are aware of this stuff just
this as a teaser sort of doesn't make me
believe that they're gonna you know
start throwing in more sophisticated
jokes for the people who pay attention
to that kind of thing because I don't
think the target demo for this and by
extension this movie really cares about
like the background behind the scenes of
what's going on with ds yeah I don't
know if those jokes are gonna matter
that much to them again looking at the
clip that's a fart joke I don't expect a
heavy amount of meta humor I guess and
not even a funny fart joke well that
that yeah yeah I was just one of those
one of those jokes that's like supposed
to be funny because of how long it's
going on but it's not that funny they
might be able to do some really cool
things with it if they decide to because
sometimes they they break out into do
some cool superpower stuff on the show
which would be cool to see but as of now
not worried is I don't really care about
the movie it would be cool if it was
cool ya know why not like I would like
it I do you have a more humorous you
know take on the DC stuff like you know
being willing to laugh at and rivet
yourself yeah
like a cool facet of the universe but at
the same time I don't know if this
iteration is for me alright guys well
are you part of the like' or dislike'
category on the teen titans go to the
movies you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified anytime one of our videos
is up and download and follow us in the
stardust app today people having a great
time posting over there are a lot more
posts to keep coming